Sure.
Throughout our entire lives we
are in search of some creed.
We seek certainty and somewhere to belong,
someone to rely upon.
You come to these things out of fear.
I mean even with videos like these,
you probably watched them
seeking some kind of certainty.
You're looking for someone
to tell you how to live.
You're probably looking for that one
video to tell you exactly what to do.
The video that will make everything click.
You seeking certainty.
It's the hearing, but there is no
such thing. Um, with that being said,
please keep watching my videos.
Hashtag I love you
encouraged by Osho. He would like to
make us more insecure, more uncertain,
because that is how life is a truly alive.
Men will always feel insecure if
anyone knew what was going to happen.
Each moment in life is just
a dead mechanical process
waiting to be played out.
A secure life would be worse than death.
When you say you are certain,
you declare your death,
you've committed suicide,
and I know one thing, this, I'll get
a lot of comments from people like,
oh well then should I just quit my job?
And go live on the streets.
And the answer I'd give
is, I don't know, man.
Maybe there isn't really
a cookie cutter answer.
Each situation is a unique
life is not a stagnant pond.
If the dynamic flowing river with
constantly changing circumstances.
Now obviously being stable and having
security is not totally a bad thing.
I talk a lot in my videos against
consumerism and materialism,
but that doesn't necessarily mean enjoying
the materialistic things of the world
is bad. Oh, show himself
the spiritual guru.
Oh 98 Rolls Royces 98 so obviously he
had an enjoyment for the material things
in life.
Does that make him incapable
of being someone you can
take wisdom and advice from
with this? I've experienced
both sides of the spectrum.
When I was 19 I landed the
secure, comfy, cushy sales job.
I thought I hit the lottery all my life.
The bar for a successful life was a
good job that you can retire on and just
like that, I already had it. I was making
more money than I knew what to do with.
And Luckily I had some good family
around me teaching me how to be frugal.
Friends told me how
jealous they were of me.
Family was telling me how proud they
were that I was successful and I was so
happy.
I had taken a risk,
moved from my small town and had all
worked out there was going to be a happily
ever after.
But soon the novelty wore off and
everyday started to look like the last and
three years past in a blur,
I knew I needed a change.
I started to spend every day at work
reading about people who are living on the
edge, people who are bold, taking
risks and making like an adventure.
I read about people saying,
fuck the standards of society.
People would sleep in their truck or
van that would airbnb and couch surf and
travel and go with their heart desired.
So eventually I got fired from this job.
I wonder why I decided to take all my
savings and spend a year sleeping out of
my truck and doing nothing but surf
and train martial arts all day.
It was scary,
but a risk I wanted to take.
Okay.
And suddenly it's like I had life
breathed back into me everyday scene,
brand new,
different from the last,
every day was a question
of where would I sleep,
what would I do and where would I go?
Until soon routine took over,
the novelty wore off and every
day seemed to be like the last
I felt exactly like I did in that
stuff to professional workplace.
I just had less space,
less things and more time and it was
never a question of having money or not
having money, having free
time, not having free time.
It was always a question of mine
awareness. It's not bad to see comfort.
It's not bad to seek the material things.
It's always a question of
the place it's coming from.
Is it coming from a place of
compulsion of seeking completion?
It didn't matter if I was at the
cushy job or living in the truck.
It was only a question of
my awareness in each moment.
I wasn't necessarily more
happy living out of the truck.
I felt happier because the danger and
novelty forced my attention into the
present moment.
What is the right thing
to do when each moment
it is that which is harmonious
with nature and with existence?
What does this even mean? What
is right? It can't be described.
This is why you must stay alert
in each moment. What is right?
One moment is wrong than that,
and you cannot depend
on ready made answers.
You must maintain awareness
to respond to a changing life.
This is why it is critical
to live a life of courage,
a life on the edge who is more aware
that the man on the edge of a cliff keep
your awareness and listen for the unknown.
Gather courage to move into it.
You will not need to seek the new for.
It will come to you in a thousand ways.
If you have the eyes to see it,
you cannot keep rejecting.
The new for the old has not given you
what you seek. No effort is needed.
Just courage.